trop département également été balayée
par la tempête xynthia qui a privé
d'électricité près d'un million de
foyers plus que 500 milles ce soir les
autres images de la tempête en
provenance de nos stations régionales le
récit de wernicke gens des rafales à 110
km heure sous l'assaut du vent et des
vagues
la mer est passé par dessus une digue à
cayeux-sur-mer dans la somme l'eau s'est
arrêté à 20 mètres seulement de cette
maison cinq ans à réau motor co les
dégâts sont considérables
ici à tour la toiture d'une école s'est
tout simplement envolé à loudun dans la
vienne
la cheminée de cette maison s'est
effondrée sur la propriétaire grièvement
blessé
donc la cheminée est partie des 2e étage
cela partait extérieur des bâtiments et
la traverse est le premier étage et est
arrivé au rez-de-chaussée sur le lit où
la dame dormait donc cette cheminée est
tombée sur ses ventes inférieure
les stations de ski des pyrénées ont été
particulièrement touchés les rafales ont
atteint 200 km heure par endroits
certaines risquent de ne pas rouvrir
cette saison autre conséquence du
passage de la tempête
des milliers d'arbres déracinés des
lignes électriques à terre et un million
de foyers privés d'électricité un peu
partout dans l'hexagone mais certains
usagers ont tout simplement allumer des
bougies et l'ont pris avec philosophie
ce programme est fait pas froid
y'a pas un temps de chien n'y a pas de
neige
on patiente et venir j'espère selon edf
2700 agents travaillent au
rétablissement des lignes
des renforts sont prévues pour demain le
retour à la normale prendra plusieurs
jours dans les zones où le réseau
électrique et le plus endommagé
il faut ajouter